today on the matt wall show the media
panics over trump questioning the
integrity of the election but the media
itself has been questioning the
integrity of his election for the past
four years
so what do we think about that also
we're going to examine the fraud claims
that are being made is there good reason
to suspect fraud and if so what should
be done about it plus democrats fight
amongst themselves
over whether socialism and leftist
extremism is the future of their party
and our daily cancellation will discuss
the radical sex ed mandate that
was just approved by the voters of
washington state all of that coming up
first
a word from lifelock you know
unfortunately
we have to tell you news of yet another
cyber attack this time the victim is
barnes and noble
the breach potentially exposed customer
data including email addresses
billing and shipping numbers telephone
numbers transaction histories all of
that the attack
also impacted the nook ebook services
some customers have been unable to
access their nook libraries
their previous purchases have
disappeared and others were unable to
log in to the the firm's online
platform this type of stuff happens all
the time and it's important to
understand
how cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day we put our
information at risk on the internet
we could miss certain identity threats
just by monitoring our credit uh
or you know taking little steps like
that that's why it's good there's
lifelong lifelock that helps detect a
wide range of identity threats
like your social security number being
for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information has been
potentially compromised they're gonna
send you an alert
they'll help you sort it out nobody can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses
but lifelock can see threats that you
might miss on your own so join now and
save
up to 25 off your first year go to
lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walsh for 25
off all right so i want to sort through
this
and tell you what i'm sort of uh
thinking i i suspect that you won't
agree with everything i have to say
that's okay
it'd be weird if you agree with me all
the time i barely agree with myself all
the time
but we're all in a position where we
have to pick our way through the weeds
through the misinformation obfuscation
fake news out of context news all of
that
as we discussed yesterday there's a
crisis of trust in this country
ultimately
one way or another we get much of our
information about world events and
political events
and the election through the media we
can't trust the media
we can't trust most politicians
government officials so
it makes it very hard to know what's
real and what isn't it requires a lot of
discernment on our part a lot of clear
thinking a lot of a lot of
intellectual honesty um and
and that's how i'm trying to approach
this and i think how we should all
try to approach it now president trump
gave a press conference last night the
media went ballistic over it
calling it an attack on our democracy
the worst thing trump has ever done
since the last worst thing he's ever
done uh here's here's how that press
conference began
listen good evening i'd like to provide
the american people with an update on
our efforts
to protect the integrity of our very
important 2020 election
if you count the legal votes i easily
win
if you count the illegal votes they can
try to
steal the election from us if you count
the votes that came in late
we're looking at them very strongly but
a lot of votes came in late
as i said the media reacted to that the
whole thing the whole press conference
with typical dramatic flair
uh here for just one example this is
anderson cooper
alleged news anchor offering his quite
objective analysis of what trump had to
say we have never seen really
other than i don't think we've ever seen
anything like this from a president of
the united states and
i think it's jake said it is it's sad
and it is truly pathetic and of course
it is dangerous and of course it will
go to courts but you'll notice the
president did not have any evidence
presented at all nothing no real
actual evidence uh of any kind of fraud
he talked about people putting up papers
and windows he talked about things that
he'd seen
on the internet that is the president of
the united states that is the most
powerful person in the world
and we see him like an obese turtle on
his back
flailing in the hot sun realizing his
time is over
but he just hasn't accepted it and he
wants to take everybody down with him
including this country
an obese turtle i bet he was proud of
that line hilarious stuff nice job
anderson
you know i could say that you look like
a cartoon seagull
if i wanted to stoop to your level i
would say that but i don't want to stoop
to your level so i'm not going to say
that
and anyway however you feel about
trump's rhetoric his
his his uh you know in his response his
fraud claims all of that
even if you think it's reckless and
dangerous and whatever else
you absolutely have no standing at all
to condemn trump much less get all high
and mighty about it if you're a democrat
because democrats for four years
accused trump of being an illegitimate
president they said it multiple times
many times over and over and over again
relentlessly they accused him of
conspiring with russia to steal our
election was there any evidence of that
no none the most they could do is tell
us that russia was
trolling on facebook and posting memes
that's the most evidence we ever were
given
and this was called rigging the election
they said that trump and russia
conspired to rig the election they then
went on to claim that trump's supreme
court justices were illegitimate they've
been saying that about amy coney barrett
after all of that you are in simply
no position to call trump a turtle
flailing at the sun
unless you want to call yourself the
same besides anyway the only turtle in
politics is mitch mcconnell and he's
more of a
ninja turtle the guy's a killer he just
doesn't lose mitch mcconnell
by the way hillary clinton in particular
has been on tv for the past four years
calling trump an illegitimate president
those words exactly here she is in 2019
three years after the election
still calling trump an illegitimate
president listen
i believe he knows he's an illegitimate
president
he knows he knows that there were
a bunch of different reasons why the
election turned out the way it did and i
take responsibility for those parts of
it that i should but jane it was like
applying for a job and getting 66
million
letters of recommendation and losing to
a corrupt human tornado and so i know
that he knows that this wasn't on the
level i don't know that we'll ever know
everything that happened
but clearly we know a lot and are
learning more every day and
history will probably sort it all out so
of course he's obsessed with me
and okay now trump is going to say the
same thing about biden
and we're going to have to listen to the
people who cheered hillary clinton
react with feigned shock and horror when
trump says
the same thing hillary clinton said
speaking of which
um here's something i'm wondering i
wonder throughout the past
four years of leftists calling trump
illegitimate calling his supreme court
picks illegitimate
advancing baseless claims of stolen
elections and election rigging and voter
suppression
has any leftist at any point anywhere
ever
been flagged censored or suspended by
twitter facebook any other big tech
company
has there been even one example that one
among the millions of of cases of this
have any of them been punished by
twitter facebook any of the rest no of
course not
meanwhile nearly everything trump is
currently tweeting is censored by by
twitter
it's completely absurd dishonest double
standards it's wrong
period obviously but what about the
claims of election fraud
is is there fraud are trump's fraud
claims different from hillary's because
his are true
well i don't know you know this this
goes back to the crisis of trust
what i can say is that you know i i
don't believe i don't i don't believe
every fraud claim i see on social media
you shouldn't either i also don't think
there's some coordinated overarching
conspiracy capable of simply fabricating
millions of votes out of thin air
if there was trump would have wouldn't
have won in 2016.
and it wouldn't be so close this year
the democrats wouldn't wouldn't have
gotten decimated in the house
also coordinated overarching
conspiracies just aren't how things work
in real life it's also not how voter
fraud works voter voter fraud is
is real and it happens but it's usually
on a small scale and it's disjointed
so to me the issue isn't conspiracy and
it has little to do with
poll workers and you know the videos
that are coming out grainy videos
that's not the point i don't think that
should be our focus
here is the point in my view i could be
wrong but this is the way that i see it
mail-in ballots an unprecedented number
of mail-in ballots democrats changed the
rules at the last minute
to get as many mail-in ballots as they
could this was done
solely only 100 percent to get rid of
trump
they knew the mail in ballots would work
in their favor so this was not about
voter participation for the sake of
participation it was about getting for
the democrats
the right kind of voters to participate
you saw how many people showed up for
trump on election day
huge turnout they knew it would go go
that way
so they changed the rules in order to
involve more of their own voters
this was all done quote legally as in
the courts approved it so
you can't overturn the results on that
basis but you can make sure that it
doesn't happen again
and and and you can forbid mass mail-in
voting in the future
if we allow it to continue i'll tell you
a republican's never going to be
president ever again
period though that isn't the problem
with mail-in voting it's not that
the problem is that it doesn't elect
republicans it's that it's highly
susceptible to mistakes
errors and outright fraud and we've seen
all of that
it also makes it harder to know if the
votes were cast within the deadline
this is all by design so the whole
mail-in system is faulty and should be
abolished entirely
with the exception of the military who
can still mail in their balance
does that mean that there's no basis to
challenge anything or you know to go to
court over this no not at all
as i said unprecedented amounts of
mail-in ballots razor thin margins
one of the closest elections ever in
history this is reason enough to go to
to do recounts to do audits
even without any notion of fraud this is
reason enough right here
this was a new system a clunky system
not well managed
and we need to make sure it worked again
i would be saying this even if there
were no claims on social media of any
fraud at all
but the fact is we do have indications
of potential fraud or irregularities or
whatever you want to call it in
pennsylvania
they allowed ballots that were not
postmarked or clearly postmarked to be
counted even if they weren't received
until three days after the election had
concluded
that's a huge problem we need to make
sure that all of those ballots were
mailed on time if they weren't they have
to be tossed
any ballot that can't be 100 confirmed
as having been sent on time
must be tossed if that means we toss
thousands of ballots so be it our
election's integrity is at stake
and in other states too there have been
huge amounts of late ballots
we need to make sure they were filed on
time we need to make sure that they were
filed
and filled out legitimately we need to
make sure people weren't
voting by mail and then in person and
that kind of thing this is all
perfectly valid grounds for litigation
take it to court and listen
if there's no solid evidence of fraud
that'll come out in court
the trump team they can't go to court
with tweets and 12-second video clips
they have to produce the goods right
show the receipts
if you think they have no goods to
produce well then you shouldn't be
worried about the courts
all the more reason to advocate for
getting the courts involved
so that's the only way to do this
all of the legal ballots should be
counted we have to make sure they're
legal
any ballots that were filed late have to
be tossed out we need to make sure
everything was done correctly
we have never had an election play out
like this that's not an exaggeration
it's never
when you look at the number of people
the number of ballots
mass mail in voting taking days to count
them all
it has never worked like this before
this is a whole new thing
and if if it went like this and it was
an absolute landslide in one direction
or another
then i think we'd have we'd have reason
to say well we're not going to recount
it's pretty clear
but that's not what happened razor thin
tight margins
and so you got to go back do some
recounts do the audits
litigate it take it to the courts um if
if the trump campaign has
evidence of voter fraud let them present
it in a court if you are against
them presenting their case in court then
that only tells me you're scared of the
case they might present
if you think it's utterly baseless then
all right
then you know what's gonna happen the
trump team will be embarrassed in court
and if you don't like trump you
shouldn't you should embrace that
opportunity
so that's the way this should go let's
get now to our five headlines
i'm excited to tell you about a new
sponsor on the show uh
that you know i'm we're a homeschool
family and i talk about that all the
time
and in fact later on in the show we're
going to talk about some some of the
more issues that you run into with
public schools and government-run
schools
so i'm a big big advocate of
homeschooling um and there are a lot i
talk to parents all the time
who who do homeschool or want to
homeschool especially now as more
more and more parents are exploring it
record numbers of parents exploring home
school
and that's why i'm excited to tell you
about homeschool magnet
uh parents who homeschool or want to
homeschool if you're overwhelmed with
all the work and responsibilities on
your shoulders right now and you know
all homeschool parents feel overwhelmed
and for parents with kids in school if
you've you know
avoided the need to pull your student
out of the public school system because
it just seems too daunting to homeschool
well then this is what you need to hear
about home school magnet it's for
parents just like you homeschool magnet
supports homeschooling families by
providing students with instruction from
world-class credentialed teachers in a
remote classroom with their peers
parents choose the best teachers for
each student based on you know the
values and the teaching approach
to ensure every child is receiving
exactly the education that they desire
so that means
that's really important you don't get
this in a government-run education
facility uh that you send you don't have
that kind of control over it's whatever
whatever the school system wants that's
what's going to be taught
here you have all the kind all the
control you want what kind of education
do you want your child to receive
not not every parent wants their child
to receive the same kind of education
and not every child should receive the
same kind of education so tailor-made
made for your students
each student will receive instruction in
the four core subject areas of math
english language arts science and social
studies parents ultimately have the
freedom to involve their student in as
much
or as little learning as they prefer
based on each student's learning goals
magnet includes a robust online learning
environment each student works from
real physical learning materials guided
by video instruction
from their teacher so it's kind of the
best of both worlds with homeschool
magnet you get the freedom and control
of homeschooling
without the burden just makes it a lot
easier it takes a lot of the pressure
off of you
to learn more about homeschool magnets
student experience go to
homeschoolmagnet.com
and join the growing wait list for
interested teachers if you're if you're
a teacher as well and you want to be
involved in this
who want more freedom in your teaching
career homeschool magnet may be perfect
for you
uh they're recruiting new teachers right
now so visit homeschoolmagnet.com
to learn more and apply okay uh five
headlines actually i lied it's not five
headlines uh i've been sort of playing
fast and loose with the format this week
because
it's a weird week in many ways so this
is one story
and it is the democrat party trying to
deal with
and understand why they didn't have the
landslide they expected
a few democrats here's the the update
here
a few democrats have actually come out
and given some valuable
insight into this question uh and and
they've been predictably ripped to
shreds because of it
most notably claire mccaskill on msnbc
talking about this subject and here she
gives i think this is the smartest
analysis that has ever been offered by
any democrat
on cable news perhaps and here it is
right here listen
it's hard to pinpoint i think it began
around cultural issues the republican
party i think very
uh adroitly adopted cultural issues as
part of their main theme
whether you're talking guns or issues
surrounding the right to abortion in
this country
or things like gay marriage and the
right for transsexuals and
and other people who we as a party have
tried to
quote unquote look after and make sure
that they're treated fairly
as we you know circle those issues we
left some voters behind and republicans
dove in with a vengeance and grab those
voters and you've seen this shift
you saw the south i've seen it in the
rural areas of my state
so we've got to get back to the meat and
potatoes issues we've got to get back to
the issues
where we are taking care of their
families and we also need to quit
acting like we're smarter than everybody
else because we're not
similar thoughts were expressed by
representative abigail spanberger
in a conference call with house with the
house democratic caucus
the contents of which were leaked on
social media
and uh here's what she said reportedly
in the conference call she said
the number one concern that people
brought to me was defunding the police
and i heard from colleagues who said oh
it's the language of the streets we
should respect that
we're in congress we're professionals
we're supposed to talk about things in a
way
where we mean what we're talking about
if we don't mean that we should defund
police
we shouldn't say that and we need to not
ever use the word socialist or socialism
ever again because while people think it
doesn't matter it does matter and we
lost good members because of that
and if we are classifying tuesday as a
success from a congressional standpoint
we will get effing torn apart in 2022.
that's what she said
part of what she said the squad of
course has uh stepped up
valiantly to you know stand against
these bursts of sanity making it clear
that no sanity will be allowed in the
democrat party at all in fact claire
mccaskill has already come out and
apologized
for for daring to be rational and
reasonable she's already had to come out
in a pile i'm so sorry about that i'm so
sorry for being reasonable
i i'll it'll never happen again i
promise you it's only happened once in
my life
that it'll be a one-time deal i promise
it will never happen again
um but these so this message is not
going to be embraced
especially by the squad and and that ilk
um
but this is of course exactly right and
we've already talked about one of the
some of the reasons why it's right uh
but
here's maybe the primary thing that it
comes down to
um you have to appeal to families if you
want to be a
a valid political party and you want to
have success
especially down the ballot you have to
appeal to families
look at president trump um his his
strongest demo
in 2020 according to exit polling data
so far was
married women i don't think anyone was
predicting that
he didn't do as well with unmarried
women but he did well with married women
it was his strongest demo
why is that well married women they have
they are
carrying you know the burdens and the
concerns of their families and they are
bringing those to the ballot box and you
have to speak to that
if you're not speaking to families
you're done you're toast and defund the
police
now uh spanberger exactly right
the defund the police may have been
maybe
the most suicidal political slogan
that's ever been adopted by a major
political party
and the democrat party did adopt it they
full-on adopted it
most mainstream democrats were going
around saying it and the rest who didn't
say it at least didn't stand up most of
them
um against it defund the police no
no no i don't care what race you are it
doesn't matter
no family wants the police defunded in
their community
that's not the priority of a family of
of someone who has kids
and all the rest of this that we get
from the democrat party they're not
they're not focused on the things that
families care about
in fact often it's quite the opposite
they're talking about tearing down the
family undermining the nuclear fight
they treat the family as a
patriarchal archaic institution
as i've been talking about all week that
kind of stuff very appealing to
you know people on college campuses uh
very appealing to some media pundits
very appealing to
antifa radicals marching in the street
presenting the nuclear family as a as a
problem that we have to do something
about
rather than supporting the nuclear
family and encouraging more families
so that that's very appealing to that so
it's not appealing to anyone else
and the thing is the the other people
families
married women they vote a lot of those
radicals in the street
they don't vote
that's that's the other dirty little
secret a lot of these people that are
marching in the street
i'm not even convinced that they really
hate trump as much as they pretend
i just don't think they care about much
of anything yeah they are they are
leftist by political persuasion but at
the end of the day they're also nihilus
and empty and uh when you're looting and
rioting and burning stuff
it's just doing it because it's
something to do destroying for the sake
of it
empty lost people
you can have a message that appeals to
empty lost people
but it's not going to appeal to families
if you're in a family you're not empty
and lost at the very least you have that
meaning in your life
you care about your family and your kids
and that's what you're worried about
when you go to the polls
so uh but this is this is not a message
that
uh the democrat party and leftists will
embrace they're not gonna they certainly
won't embrace it for me
they won't even embrace it from their
own so uh and
i guess that's all the better for
republicans at least down the ballot
all right let's get to our daily
cancellation now for our daily
cancellation today we're canceling the
entire state of washington
a great many potential and excellent
reasons could be given for canceling
washington state but
the focus for me today is the first ever
voter approved
sex ed mandate which was just passed by
referendum on election day
and there's a lot of other things
happening with the election but we can't
lose sight of this voters in washington
proved a measure
to mandate that schools in the state
teach
so-called comprehensive sex
ed to all students starting in
kindergarten now for more on the
original bill
which sparked this referendum uh let me
read some of the some of life site
news's
coverage from a few months ago this is
what they say pro family advocates have
sounded the alarm by highlighting the
graphic lessons of sex ed curricula
that meet the bill's standards a sex-ed
curriculum by the pro-abortion pro-lgbt
group
advocates for youth meets the bill
standards and is already used in some
washington schools called
3r it heavily promotes gender theory
promiscuity condoms and contraception
and abortion as well as what is listed
at the beginning
uh of the article the three the three r
curriculum also directs teachers to have
14 year old students role play
negotiating for sex
teachers are warned that if two
cisgender heterosexual boys
end up randomly being assigned to each
other for this exercise quote it is
possible they will have a homophobic
response
a three-hour lesson plan called creating
condom confidence
has ninth graders practice putting
condoms on bananas or penis models
their homework assignment is to quote
see what it's actually like to try to
try to get them yourselves students are
told they have a right to access condoms
at any age
and that adults who make comments about
them purchasing condoms can be reminded
uh can be reminded of that other
messages contained in the state approved
material she says include
instructions on bondage and quote
body fluid play how males can allegedly
have
babies and uh why they should be allowed
on girls sports teams and how to obtain
abortions
cross-sex hormones and hpv vaccinations
without parental involvement now okay
this is a state-approved sex ed
curriculum defenders of the mandate will
point out that the mandate doesn't tell
schools they have to adopt
that curriculum fine but that's like
passing a bill
saying everyone has to eat a lump of
crap for breakfast
and someone objects and says i don't
want to eat dog crap for breakfast
and you respond well you don't have to
eat dog crap you could eat whatever kind
of crap you want
crap is crap comprehensive sex education
is comprehensive sex education
it is all basically the same it's all
basically like what i just read to you
the bill mandates comprehensive sex ed
and this is what comprehensive sex ed is
this is what it contains
this is the point of it to brainwash
kids into this way of thinking and
acting
to this world view this attitude about
sex
that means gender identity
transgenderism the 53 genders whatever
all that's part of it too it's
automatically a part of it
because again that's what comprehensive
sex ed is
and that's what it means so think about
what the voters of washington have done
here
they have gone to the polls and voted
for the government to sexually groom
their own children
it's pretty mind boggling if you think
your child should be
told about all these things then why
don't you just tell them yourself
i mean i don't think you should but but
asking the government to do it
willingly passing this whole subject off
to the state
is lunacy the voters of washington are
asking the government to corrupt their
children they're saying please
uncle sam please this is
this is not democracy's finest moment i
guess we could say nor a great argument
for it
to be frank now anytime this
conversation about sex ed comes up i'm
always asked
well matt if you don't believe in
comprehensive sex ed for kids then
what kind of sex ed do you support
that's an easy answer
because for me the answer is none
nothing
i don't support any form of sex ed in
school at all
i'm not advocating abstinence education
no i i don't want government schools
teaching my kids about how to abs uh
abstain from sex
i don't want them teaching them anymore
teaching them how to abstain from sex
any more than i want them teaching
my kids how to have sex i want them
giving no
tips no advice no moral lessons no
instruction of any kind
on this subject except for on a purely
scientific and biological basis
teach them about human reproduction yes
fine this is how babies are made
and that's it when to have sex should
you have sex
how to have sex what types of sex to
have none of those topics should be
covered or approached
by government employees talking to a
room full of children
it's not their business it's not their
place it's not why schools exist
and in fact talking about the the you
know basic birds and bees abcs of of sex
human reproduction the biology yeah
that's something that
you don't need a sex ed curriculum for
that much less a quote-unquote
comprehensive sex ed
uh curriculum and it doesn't need to
start in kindergarten either
that's something that you you cover in
science class biology class
you have a biology lesson it's going to
cover human reproduction that's all you
need to say now the problem is
that we're at the point now where i
don't trust the government to teach that
either
10 years ago my argument was they should
just teach
the basics of biological reproduction
now actually
i don't even trust them with that
because
that means given how schools are run and
the ideology that reigns supreme in
schools
uh that means they're going to be
teaching the kids that men can reproduce
now i i would like to see that lesson
plan in the biology textbook i'd like to
see how they explain that
but that's the view that's the worldview
they're approaching this from
so even that we're getting to a point
where even that can't be approached but
i i in an ideal scenario
um the schools would teach the actual
biological facts of sex when it you know
whenever that comes up in the in the
curriculum
in biology class in science class uh
and uh and then and then that's it and
then and then you know so it's it's
science and then you're also teaching
math and history and english and writing
uh and all of that we don't need to get
into anyone's
opinions anyone's world view about sex
when you when you attach the word
comprehensive in front of it
um what that means is we are getting
the the teachers worldview their
opinions
about sex and sexuality
or the world view and the opinion of
the people who came up with the
curriculum and the materials
in this case planned parenthood in
washington state they've been
huge advocates of this of this
referendum of this bill this mandate
they they love it so this is the planned
parenthood
far left extreme world view attached to
it
but as i said i i don't think and this
is why it annoys me that
the debate over sex ed for so long has
been
uh should it be liberal comprehensive
sex ed or should it be abstinence
education no i i don't think the
solution here
is to um give
have the kids sit in a classroom with 30
other kids have a government employee
talk to them about sex
but instead of approaching it from a
leftist worldview approach it from a
conservative christian worldview
no no i don't want my kids sitting there
you know the the the argument or the um
the reasons why children should
abstain from sex um there are a lot of
very good reasons for it
the reasons why you should wait for
marriage to have sex
a lot of great reasons for that i don't
trust my kids health teacher if i sent
them to public school which i don't but
i wouldn't trust my kids health teacher
to handle that subject
and make those arguments and present
that case in a competent way
i just don't trust them to do it far too
delicate
far too important and i don't think and
even if i did trust the teacher which i
don't
i don't think sitting in a classroom
with 30 other kids is the right
environment for that talk
so get that out of the schools let
parents handle it
uh it's that's something for the family
for the home
it's not for schools and but
voters in washington state they want the
school to do it
they're saying hands off i'll just i'll
send my my five-year-old over to you
guys
and you do with him what you will turn
him into whatever you want to turn him
into
i'm hands-off i mean what am i the
parent
because of that they are canceled
and we'll leave it there today thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright dailywire2020
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there
you